بالنظر الى حجم الكارثه الكبير هناك مناطق
سكنيه هناك شوارع اختفت تماما
بالتاكيد احمد بالتاكيد الكبير
والمصاب جلال هناك بالتاكيد ونتفاهم
مشاعرك
انتهت حلول الارض الامر متروك للسماء هكذا
تعلنها ليبيا المقابر عجزت وتصرخ هذا يكفي
والمستشفيات تعلنها لقد امتلات لا مكان
للمزيد الدموع تنهمر وتسيل حتى على جدران
الابنيه وتصبح اغزر من المطر وصوت الشعب
يتحد على جمله واحده يقولها في نبره حزينه
وداعا ايها الاحبه احياء كامله تختفي من
على الخريطه وسكانها اما قتل او مفقودين
ابراج شاهقه تسقط في ثوان قليله كاوراق
الشجر في الخريف ومدن عامره تتحول في مشهد
درامي الى ركام لا يسمع فيها صوت واصبحت
خاويه على عروشها كل شيء يب في ليبيا
والجميع يوجه يده نحو السماء داعين انقذنا
يا الله كيف حول اعصار دانيال ليبيا الى
ماتم كبير وكم وصل عدد القتلى والمفقودين
جراء الاعصار المدمر حتى الان وماذا تقول
توقعات حول عدد القتل الحقيقي وما هي
الدول التي اسرعت بمساعده الشعب الليبي في
مصيبته لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه
ياء تند
ثر لم يكد الشعب لبيو يتنفس الهواء عاقبه
داعيات الحرب والانقسامات ليفاجئ باعصار
دانيال الشرس يقتحم مدنه دون سابق انذار
الرياح تغزو شرق ليبيا بسرعه تتخطى 70
كيلومترا في الساعه وامطار غزيره تنهمر
بشكل مرعب كانها رصاص يهبط من السماء لا
يمكن وصف شده السيول ولكن يكفي ان تعرف
انها كانت تجرف ابنيه عاليه بسكانها وتلقي
بهم في البحر مدد الشرق كالبيضاء وبني
غازي والمرج والجبل الاخضر تحولت جميعها
الى مدن المنكوبه اما مدينه درنه فتلك
مصيبه كبرى وحدها فقد اختفت فيها مناطق
بسكانها من على الخريطه واصبح حالها خارجا
تماما عن السيطره فما الذي حدث في تلك
المدينه المنكوبه
مشاهد تحبس الانفاس
دمرت السيول السدين اللذين كان يحصنان
المدينه وجرفت الكثير من الاحياء السكنيه
بمبانيها واهلها واغرقتهم بالكامل في مياه
البحر اصبح معظم المدينه تحت الماء ناهيك
عن تدمير اعمده الكهرباء واسقاط عشرات
الابنيه الشاهقه التي تحولت الى ركام في
ثوان معدوده اما بالنسبه للضحايا فلا احد
يعلم عدد الذين ابتلعتهم الارض في البدايه
قيل انهم 150 قتيلا وفجاه تحول الرقم الى
الفيقتين لا يا عزيزي انها ليست النهايه
فقد تجاوز عدد القتل الان
4,500 قتيل وعشرات الالاف من المفقودين كل
هذا في مدينه درنه وحدها تظن انها العدد
الحقيقي النهائي معذره يا هذا فالكارثه
اكبر بكثير من ان يستوعبها عقل البشر
تقول ان عدد القتل سيصل وربما يتخطى
العشره الاف قتيل اما عن عدد المفقودين
فحدث ولا حرج فمن المتوقع ان يتجاوز عددهم
المئه الف مفقود في دارنا خرج الامر عن
سيطره السلطات الليبيه وتم اعلانها مدينه
منكوبه حتى الصليب الاحمر الذي سار علي
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه اعلن مقتل ثلاثه من
اعضائه اثناء عمليه الانقاذ وان الوضع في
المدينه ضبابي ولا يمكن تحديد اي شيء
مناطق اشباع
وكانها عادت الى عصور الظلام انقطعت كل
طرق الاتصال بمدن شرق ليبيا امتلات
الشوارع بالجثث وما تحت الارض كان اعظم
واصبحت احيان تلك المدن اشبه بمناطق اشباه
تم فرض حظر تجوال في مدينه درنه وبقي مدن
الشرق الليبي واضطرت السلطات الى اغلاق
المدارس وكل المؤسسات الحكوميه واوقفت
العمل باربعه موانئ نفطيه الرئيسيه اي
كارثه كانت في انتظاركم يا محارب الصحراء
ادمت ليبيا القلوب وزرفت من اجلها الدموع
وهنا جاء دور الاشقاء فقد سارعت مصر وتونس
والجزائر بالتنسيق مع السلطات الليبيه
بارسال المساعدات الماديه والبشريه للمدن
المتضرره وقامت قطر والعديد من الدول
العربيه بنفس الشيء الكل يحاول تقديم
المساعده ولكن الكارثه فعلا اكبر من يد
البشر الان السؤال لكم مشاهدينا الى اين
ستتجه ليبيا بعد تلك الكارثه وهل ما حدث
هو غضب من الله ام انه كارثه طبيعيه كان
من الممكن تفاديها قبل وقوعها
اخون صندوق التعليقات